STOCKS MIXED TODAY.
DOW GAINED 37.
A SUMMARY OF A HUNDRED DROP 2.
NASDAQ LOST 26.
RESIDENTS IN THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST MAY SOON BE PAYING A
LOT MORE IN TAXES TO FIGHT A
MAN-MADE CLIMATE CHANGE PROCESS
WHICH MANY PEOPLE SAY HAS NEVER
BEEN SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, SOME OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING THAT
PLAN.
DAN SPRINGER FEELS LISTEN FROM
SEATTLE.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO GREENHOUSE
GASES, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID
THAT HE WILL PULL BEING THE
THOUGHT THE PARIS CLIMATE
AGREEMENT.
AIMING TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AS A
WAY TO STOP GLOBAL WARMING.
WESCO STATES ARE DRIVING
INHIBITS THE DIRECTION WITH
REFERENCE TO TAX CARBON >> THIS
IS AN ECONOMIC BENEFIT FOR
WASHINGTON, JOB CREATION.
JOBS IN THE CLEAN ENERGY SECTOR
GROWING TWICE AS FAST AS THE
REST OF THE ECONOMY.
WASHINGTON STATE'S GOVERNOR
WANTS TO TAX RESIDENTS EVERY
TIME THEY FILL UP AT THE PUMP,
BUSINESSES LIKE BOEING THAT
THEY HAD TO RESIDENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES, $3.3 BILLION OVER
FOUR YEARS.
THAT MONEY WOULD GO TO GREEN
INDUSTRIES.
>> NOT JUST SUBSIDIZING CLEAN
ENERGY.
HELPING THE ENVIRONMENT, YOU'RE
ALSO SUBSIDIZING A BIG EXPANSION
IN GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY WHICH
DOES NOTHING TO HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT.
>> BRITISH COLUMBIA WAS SLIVERS
OF NORTH AMERICA TAX CARBON INTO
THOUSAND EIGHT.
THE RESULTS MOSTLY GOOD.
THE MISSIONS ARE SLIGHTLY DOWN
EVEN AS THE POPULATION IN THE
FOR HIGHER ENERGY COSTS.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM WHILE OREGON
LAWMAKERS SIMILAR PLAN.
ALL AN ATTEMPT TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR.
>> CARBON TAX CORRECTS FOR THE
MARKET FAILURE.
SPEAK OF THE FATE OF THE CARBONT
SPEAK OF THE FATE OF THE CARBONX
BILL IS UNCERTAIN.
SIMILAR MOVEMENT FORMING IN THE
NORTHEAST.
BILL INTRODUCED IN MASSACHUSETTS
WITH TAX ENERGY USE BUT RESIDENT